hey wisecrack Jared again while you guys
probably think of key & peele as the duo
that gave us President Obama's anger
translator or the visionaries that
finally made an action movie about a
kitten they're also responsible for some
of the smartest comedy that's recently
graced the airwaves and while much of
their success can be chalked up to their
unique and often absurd characters their
true brilliance lies in their
streamlined writing style and a
commitment to sketches that are as funny
big time what like Atlanta as they are
socially and emotionally true oh you are
and how do they tell that truth well
let's find out since nothing is better
than over explaining a joke welcome to
this wisecrack edition on Key & Peele
and I guess there's sort of spoilers
ahead to really understand what makes
heum peels so great we need to look a
bit deeper and discover the comedic
philosophy that informs their work and
believe it or not these guys follow in
the footsteps of this guy for those of
you unfamiliar that isn't the demon love
child of Dan Harmon Alan Moore and
Schley Boise Jack that's Del Close a
pioneer of comedy who's still hugely
influential today but before we get into
how can peel embody closes comedic
philosophy we need to take a look at a
little comedy science while you probably
don't dissociate science with comedy we
can better understand the success of
many key and Peele sketches by
distilling them down to a core comedic
structure in this structure we start in
a world with a built-in set of
expectations which is then contrasted
with an unusual behavior and this
behavior is heightened and explored
until you've pissed yourself from
laughing so hard
in other words comedy has arrived at
through exploring a behavior that breaks
with the expectations we have of a given
situation if we wanted to go full
beautiful mind on this structure it
might look a little something like this
reasonable reality and set of
expectations Plus unusual behavior
and/or point of view x raised emotional
stakes plus an ending which subverts
established pattern equals comedy bliss
but enough comedic calculus let's take a
look at substitute teacher as an
the sketch opens in a high school
classroom an environment that carries
with it a set of standard expectations
bored students chalkboards books and a
teacher trying to wield some authority
but all this changes when mr. Garvey
begins taking attendance Jay Quellin
where's Jay Quellin net no Jay Quellin
here do you mean Jacqueline now that we
have our unusual behavior ie mr.
Garvey's inability to pronounce
stereotypically white names things can
really get cookin we get to see both the
logic behind mr. Garvey's frustration
I'm for real I'm real along with the
increasingly terrified students as mr.
Garvey continues this unusual behavior
is anger increases while their fear
heightens this simple underlying logic
is what helps accelerate the comedy with
each move once we see this pattern
repeated a few times
we're already predicting the next move
but not to be bested by an attentive
audience the sketch ends by flipping our
expectations for once mr. Garvey gets it
right Timothy present thank you let's
see how this pattern plays out in some
other sketches for example we expect a
babysitter to have a quiet night but an
unusual behavior is introduced googoo
gaga
[Music]
0:01 milk and this behavior gets
emotionally heightened the orange hunch
of me in my house ok it's time for bed
with a last-minute reveal that offers a
glimpse into the comedic logic hush baby
forced Whittaker don't say a word
no gaga Mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird in another sketch we start
with a fairly mundane setting until we
meet our unusual companions who are
intent on living their vigilante air
marshal dreams I tell you one thing if
9/11 or to happen up on this airplane
don't worry we got there
the stakes are then raised well above
cruising altitude you know I'm working
up death
and rather than fizzling out by running
the pattern into the ground we get a
surprise at the end that reframes what
we've just seen of course we know that
sketches that don't follow this pattern
can also be hilarious who can deny the
pure joy of Will Ferrell's gyrating
midriff I gotta have my cowbell or the
Wonder is testicular double entendre of
Alec Baldwin's baked goods no one can
resist my Schweddy boys and he'll even
key and Peele occasionally bask in the
purely absurd comedic structure is only
half the story while their sketches are
certainly funny it's another element of
their work that ensures that they're
also smart he appeals commitment to
finding fundamental human truth in
comedy this philosophy is not an
invention of key and Peele however they
both cut their comedic chops in Chicago
a city whose comedy scene is permeated
by this guy dell clothes and while you
may not have heard of him he's
responsible for training a few decent
comedians and along the way he helped
write a book called truth and comedy
with Sharna Halpern that's become a
Bible for comedians around the world in
it they argue that the best comedy comes
from mining the depths of human
existence and that this creates the
grounds for comedy that is both funny
and smart an idea that we see everywhere
in key and Peele
oh and Del Close once claimed that a
coven of witches cured him of his
cocaine addiction this has nothing to do
with comedy but I think it's worth
noting this commitment to truth isn't
exclusive to Chicago comedians as this
emotionally honest style has dominated
recently from the diner to the break
room to the streets of Italy
now does this commitment to truth mean
that good comedy always has to reflect
on real and truthful situations hell no
but while a post-apocalyptic alien
invasion might not reflect the reality
of the world we live in
sorry to anyone currently on acid the
core comedic idea is still grounded in
something fundamentally true that key
appeals characters can instantly know
who is an alien by their reaction to
blackness wait how did you know
come on redneck wants us to move into
his community us the friendlier the
white characters are the more certain
they are of their alien nature would you
let me date your daughter let's return
to mr. Garvey what's the truth that
makes this sketch so funny for a start
this sketch reverses the trope of a
well-intentioned Teach for America type
out to save a bunch of inner-city kids
this role reversal produces both the
immediate comedy of mr. Garvey's
mispronunciations and the socially
conscious fact that this is something
that happens to minority students all
the time except in that case it's more
uncomfortable than it is funny while mr.
Garvey's reaction to a name like Denis
and Aaron are hilarious key and Peele
are forcing us to ask a more complicated
question what if black teachers were as
culturally incompetent as their white
counterparts and thus we have a double
pronged comedic attack come for the
laughter and stay for the socially
conscious criticism the benefit of this
mixture of comedic structure and finding
the truth is that hilarious sketches can
be found in any area of life race
religion the dark side of professional
sports you name it and they often do so
by relating to personal experience in
their first sketch titled I said
there's a focus on the tensions found in
black masculinity between being a strong
alpha male and a committed partner I
look this woman I said [ __ ] you told me
6:45 you said that the sketch heightens
the limits that two friends will go to
to keep up the facade of being a
hard-ass
getting further and further away from
their spouses in the process and the
interstellar lengths they'll go to to
maintain this facade represent the
actual effort men will put in to prove
they're one of the bros and of course
this sketch highlights the absurdity of
this whole macho performance
this theme is also explored in the
expanded key & peele universe as their
first feature film Keanu throws to
normal suburban black men into the world
of organized crime and drug dealing
where they have to impersonate two
legendary Street assassins at one point
we see the two main characters
performing a stereotypical sort of black
masculinity real quick and conversely we
see some of the hardened gangsters
brought to tears by the music of George
Michael they use a similar strategy in
the sketch office homophobe where we see
a tense interaction between two office
mates I see so you can't handle hearing
about how I'm gay I'm sorry you just
referred to your boyfriend's penis as a
baby's arm holding an apple which leads
to a serious accusation yo homophobic
and while this sketch at first seems to
set up a tired trope in which the humor
is derived from a flamboyant gay
stereotype that's disgusting
oh I see so you don't want to see a
close-up picture of my anus because you
hate gay man this expectation is upended
when the homophobes boyfriend shows up
it's my boyfriend how you doing I'm
doing very well which leads to a
surprising realization for Keyes
character I get it I'm not persecuted
I'm just an ass and the truth of this
sketch well no matter your sexual
preference or gender identity you can
still be an [ __ ] a more common source
of comedic inspiration has always been
good old-fashioned religion and
critiques of religion are not new when
it comes to both big-time major-league
bull you have to stand in awe in awe of
the all-time champion of false promises
and exaggerated claims religion but
rather than following in the footsteps
of those who find comedy in skewering
religion for its irrational claims key
and Peele find a much more human take on
religion and in particular Christianity
the sketch opens with a group of earnest
believers in prayer and this group of
Christians is rewarded with a visit from
the voice of God himself
however once God responds to their
prayers with some practical next steps I
want you to sell everything you own
immediately begin service to the pool
they become slightly less enthused
eventually they find a nice loophole to
avoid having to actually follow God's
command of service this sketch is so
great because it offers a funny critique
of religion with some genuine
theological nuance the joke isn't on
religion in general or believers in
particular rather it points out the
hypocrisy of those unwilling to take
their own religious traditions seriously
when it comes to following through on a
not so fond obligation this critique is
actually one founded in Christianity
itself as the book of James famously
says faith without works is dead even
your most devout ons couldn't disagree
with this one and even more brutally
honest social critique can be seen in
their sketch sound off which is set at
basic training while we assume that the
drill sergeant is going to leave the
song in some absurd direction it ends up
finding comedy in a place of harsh
realism the sketch doesn't only point
out the disparity in who ends up
fighting America's Wars but also the
reality of what awaits soldiers coming
home from war somehow they manage to
make a sketch about economic inequality
and inadequate medical care in the
military funny while they have multiple
sketches that use the absurdity of
football for comedic fuel
in quarterback concussion they use the
trope of the heroic quarterback to shine
some light on the medical reality of the
game after taking a big hit we see the
quarterback go from confused seriously
by what what are we doing too quickly
offering fictional baked goods all you
have to do is ask man is trying to have
a Potter go around before getting
diagnosed by a teammate you have a brain
injury but after seemingly getting it
together in a rousing chance of team
spirit
[Music]
the quarterback notices a missing piece
of his identity as a rhino oh my god
somebody saw and runs off in an
effective parody of the inspirational
sports movie genre key and Peele are
showing us what it would look like if
these movies accurately represented the
horrific injuries suffered by athletes
while that's just a few examples Kim
peels five seasons plus Keanu are filled
with hours of insanely smart and
insanely funny sketches and because most
of their work is grounded in true human
emotions and situations rather than
topical humor these sketches really hold
up but most importantly can peel serve
as a reminder for the greatness of the
TSA I'm TS mother hey so if you see any
terries trying to get froggy you should
always remember to drag down spouts
thanks for watching guys peace if you
guys want to hear more we just released
the first episode of the wise crack
podcast where we break down every
episode of this season of Rick and Morty
so check the description to find out how
you can find our podcast on iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play or anything else
also we want to thank you guys for all
the support we love making videos for
you guys and really couldn't do it
without you so thank you thank you thank
you for everything y'all do another way
you can support us is by becoming a
patron you'll get immediate access to
exclusive patron only releases including
podcasts on Wonder Woman and Spider Man
my video on daddy issues in guardians of
the galaxy part 2 and a new video on the
possible meta commentary behind
Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk
and we're working on more patient
exclusive content each month including
behind-the-scenes experiments with new
formats quick takes and more so be sure
to check out our patreon page at the
link in the description don't forget to
subscribe and ring that bell to always
be in the know on what we're up to
thanks y'all peace
[Music]